my friend who i adore and love and i
already miss even though i saw him just
a couple wednesdays ago for the schedule
release show
pro football hall of famer michael irvin
how are you sir
what's up i i am doing well man
i am doing well rich let me tell you
what's funny now yes
deciphering exactly what aaron rodgers
said
that that now and we're in the business
of this yes we are
and i've been scratching my head with
that
for a while i said i know he's not
running for president but he with this
for the people and the people and i it
was that was that was that was
interesting well
i think he's the people and the the the
people
who's not considering the people in the
organization or the general manager and
the
and the team president who's essentially
the owner who represents the uh
the the ownership group uh and mark
murphy i mean clearly that's what he's
talking about
and you know even though he said he's
still it's not about the draft pick it
still is
about the draft pick it's about the fact
that they started a clock on his window
closing
which you which any team that chooses a
quarterback in the first round and
in an era where you've got it three
years to figure out whether they deserve
a fifth year option
he knows the clock started the minute
that happened and yeah
i think that's what i heard what i'm
saying is
i understand this world that we live in
let's uh and we we have to present this
front
and present that this is the reason it's
called just be real
just say hey listen you guys know like i
know this is a business
and they're going to try to do me dirty
i'm beating them through it
we got to go through all of this we
don't have to go through all this
they're going to do me dirty down the
road
so i'm just beating them too feeding
them to it
i'm going to do them dirty so so we can
all
love the packers and he loves the
packers just like the fans love the
packers but for the football player
if if you don't do it a certain way then
you're being disloyal
he has he's loyal to the pockets but he
has to be loyal to him too
and and he saw what tom brady went
through
you know what i'm saying so he's like i
know if they didn't show tom brady
any capitulation and great love why am i
going to ride this
out why i got the hammer let me hit the
nail
let me swing it and he's swinging it
it's about
that that's all it's about you don't
gotta give me the
the president's speech about the people
and the people
for the people and the people he is
about i can tell you the people he's
really about
and i don't mind i love america and i
think that roger has every right to be
doing what he's doing
because it is a business and the thing
is we got so much passion in the game of
football
that we want to just see the passion and
the football
but this is big business and aaron
rodgers
is doing big business and so when aaron
rodgers
is talking about the people let me tell
you the people
he's talking about ben franklin thomas
jefferson
all of those people that own dollar
bills that would give him more power
and then and let him consider his own
future and now you consider
those are the people he's talking about
but not ulysses grant right you know
what you're on 50s right you don't have
50
bills right we're talking about ben
franklin um
you know i guess that's about it no he
he wants them all
he wants tomorrow george george thomas
jefferson
uh abe lincoln andrew jackson those are
the people
i knew you were going in that way too i
knew you were going dead presidents i
knew it
i definitely knew it that's exactly
those are the people he's talking about
and that makes sense
but we we can't just say that we can't
say the organization
those are the people they're talking
about because they're trying to figure
out the best way they can get top play
without giving out too many of those
people without giving out being frankly
in the thomas jefferson and
george washington how can we get top
play without giving out those people how
can we get the power that's all
that's all the people we talking about
when we're talking football now let's
move on to the people that we're talking
about my people the dallas cowboys
let's do that michael let's do that by
the way before we talk about
uh julio jones and the dallas cowboys uh
even though we just
spent a few minutes on the packers i do
want to let you know that you are on
live television before we have this
conversation
okay
yes you know that that that's a that's a
thin
line and it's in it and it's it's it's a
tough line to walk
because you know we know guys you know
we're friendly with guys and we know how
we talk how we talk
but but now you're coming into the
business and that whole situation
hey oh shannon's not santa's not in the
ambushing business shannon's one of the
best people in the world the reason
they call shannon uncle is because he's
like that awk
that's what a lot of young guys in the
league called me today what's up
you know what's up because you know
you're like that uncle
that that comes over and everybody's
cool with you know
i i didn't take offense to julio
and first of all for julio to say he's
not thinking about the dallas cowboys
how did you how could you reach down
grab that shirt see
the name written across that shirt
in your brain not sink on lining up
for that star on your helmet it's
impossible
in this situation it's impossible
for this to be real reality you had to
think about it
that's why you put it on julio knew what
he was doing he knew
he was stirring the pot when he chose to
put that shirt on
and he put that shirt on and got what he
wanted because
this pot this pot stirs the real big pot
that dallas cowboy pie serves real big
pot see so so
so that's the reality so the real do
that the real big
shirt on the real big pot is the nfl
there's someone following you what
you're saying that the dallas cowboy pot
stirs
absolutely absolutely hey hey i tell you
what
if he had put on uh uh uh
uh any other shirt it wouldn't have
gotten
oh ain't no doubt we would talk about it
we would talk about it if he had a saint
shirt on we would talk about it if he
had on another team shirt
but it shall not be talked about with
the same passion
in the same intensity if he had that on
it will not be a story ran for more than
one day
if he had another jersey on that's
exactly what i'm talking about
and so when he comes on and talk about
he knows what he's going to get in
dallas
uh he's just butting up to um that's awk
talk
that's all that is he he knows his uncle
don't like the cowboys so at the time
he's just butting on up the um you know
what he is that's
brother-in-law i call that brother ology
brotherology
they're just talking brother to brother
he can't wait
now i understand if julio was coming
from new england
and was questioning the winning that was
going on in dallas
but he's not coming from new england
he's coming from atlanta
how can you question the winning or lack
thereof that's going on in dallas
when you're coming from atlanta you
understand what i'm talking about if we
do a comparative analysis
on the two atlanta would be like
oh they're low city atlantis the dallas
is ubiquitous
it's everywhere we can't find atlantis
but we can find dollars everywhere so
you can't
say that oh oh oh oh we know we're gonna
lose over there
because you've been losing in atlanta
you see what i'm saying so so i know he
didn't mean that
he was just doing um talk and he's a
great dude that's just um so unk talk
again you're referring to shannon sharp
and by the way i
i agree with you i don't think shannon
called him up to say i'm going to get
him to say something
and and i think he just left on on
not being on tv as long as say you
or you know others he just whiffed on
not saying hey heads up we're on we're
on the air right now
uh right right right you know why he did
everything i'll give him that benefit
be right right he ain't trying to only
i'ma tell you this and
i'll go this forward please i'm gonna
give you some more brother all of you he
he he only did it because he knows julio
is without reap without reproach
he ain't got no problem you julio what
he's going to say is
you know you know i know that that's the
worst he's going to say
now that was me he knew he couldn't
leave me out there like that with all
these skeletons falls out the clock
right away well you're going to kill me
right away
but we're on tv
so he knows julio was above reproach
right you can't find that bad on julio
but but so so as he said knows
how to talk to a brother uh um well but
he definitely called him up to
to to troll on the cowboys that was the
purpose of his phone call absolutely but
he also didn't know i mean
it's not the obviously that's not the
first time that he i'm sure
and julio jones have spoken in the past
few weeks uh he you know he also said
you're going to stay in atlanta and he
probably knew what the answer to that's
going to be
certainly if ian rappaport said that
julio's been asking for a trade
for months he said months ago is where
it was so let's dive into that uh
in our last portion of this conversation
michael irvin is
why do you think julio wants out like
what what do you think is
up with that that that he asked for a
trade
from atlanta and he's like i'm out of
there when
there is matt ryan and kyle pitts and
calvin ridley and
and and uh an offense that you could say
is one of the best in the nfl coming
into this year
why do you think he wants out michael
yeah
it's scary that that if those guys could
all be working together in harmony that
would be absolutely scary when you talk
about pitts
wrigley and and jones julio man that
would be like oh my god
that would just be a scary thing but but
obviously what happens here man is is
we're dealing with emotions we're
dealing with emotions
you know you served the place so long
like dan rogers you served the place
you've given you all
and you've done it absolutely right
there's no like i said no pro
there's nothing you can come at this man
with he's been great
absolutely right and then you start
hearing all of these
rumors about being traded and then it's
not it's okay you hear about being
traded
you also hear why they trying to trade
you they think you're on the dole or
you're on the back end
they don't believe he can do it anymore
this
is what made him great he didn't listen
to people then so now
he's not going to listen now he's going
to show you i still have it in me
and that's cool i'll show you i'm out of
here and the emotions get involved in it
and gets in the way so so yeah yeah
i i understand him saying that that that
yeah he's out of here
because he's hurt right now because
everybody keeps bringing him up
in the in the trade talk i also think
that uh you know
uh it's the brady thing you know you
mentioned brady in reference to rogers
earlier in this conversation we had
matthew stafford on the show yesterday
he
he he has said in print and and
essentially
uh repeated it when he when i asked him
about it seeing brady
do what he did after 20 years going
somewhere else and
maybe everybody figures hey 11 12 years
in one spot it's enough
let me go somewhere else where where i
will be far more appreciated they won't
be capped this cap that they'll
you know new coach this new coach that
i'll choose a new coach not not have it
chosen for me
maybe that's part of what he's going
through right now at the end of his
career
anyway right right but but but only
after after you realize
okay they're not going to get treat me
like they used to treat me and they're
not going to give me what i feel i
deserve
tom didn't choose to leave all together
like if tom had his choice they were
there to bring in more help
that had done things differently and he
would have wanted to stay right here i'm
sure he would have anyone to finish his
career new england
but since all of those things didn't
happen and and they
they were getting ready to show him the
door
he went on and did what he had to do
which absolutely
helps other guys like julio and aaron
rodgers saying wait a minute wait a
minute
because it's the thing that i remember
when when lebron and d wade was talking
about it in basketball
they said you saw they got rid of
michael jordan so
one day they're going to get real if
they got rid of michael jordan they're
going to get rid of us
and rogers them they're saying the same
thing this is the reality of the game
so they're trying to beat you toward and
right now julio jones
he said i i'll show you he's hurt and
i'll show you
and yeah i'll go somewhere else and get
it i don't think julio really
wants to leave i think his pain uh of of
this last
last year here is going to help him make
a decision that i want out well and then
in terms of that that let's finish up
with that michael irvin is where
where he might go next um we could not
help but notice and we wonder if you saw
as well on instagram at michael irvin88
deandre hopkins putting out a photograph
of him
um is that cal that's uh aj green in his
bengals hat
uh and julio um and deandre hopkins all
around
you at a pro bowl and it says julio you
remember what we talked about
jaylen ramsay chimed in relax um
so you know obviously jalen can only
take one of these guys
uh on the screen aj and deandre together
in arizona
what did you guys talk about that day
[Music]
what did you what was discussed on that
day
that's funny right there rich that is
funny but but but
i tell you this now i have had
conversations with of course with
with deandre and julio and all of those
and we've talked the business of the
business
just what we're talking about right now
the business of the business
we we had that conversation that pro
bowl i don't remember what year that was
that was years and years ago
we had a conversation we had this
conversation we're having right now
about the business of the business
uh well a year and a half ago two years
ago when the deandre hopkins stuff broke
that's
i was on the phone with those two guys
and we were talking in the business
of the business and they were already
preparing and talking about this talking
about hey you know these things that's
what they're going to try to do so you
know
let's try to make sure we maximize
whatever we have it's business
that's it i'm telling you these guys are
older these guys are different now it's
not just about football these are
these guys see themselves as each
individual business and businessmen and
and they're trying to handle themselves
accordingly and they're very very
uniquely gifted kids you listen
uniquely gifted athletes like julio
jones
uh other deandre hopkins those guys are
going to try to
control more of their future than than
just sitting around and letting people
are letting front officers do what they
want to do knowing
that ultimately they're trying to
replace so you're saying there was no
you're saying basically michael irvin
that that that deandre hopkins is
reminding julio jones
about the business of of business and
and he should utilize his business
acumen right now it just so happens that
aj green is in that photograph with
deandre hopkins and that they're current
teammates in arizona that is just pure
coincidence he's just reminding him
about making a business decision and a
smart one that's all you're saying
michael you you
so you you think in this thing aj green
all these guys playing on the same team
yes uh
you you're gonna go we're gonna build a
super team
yeah for conor mcgregor that's one way
to keep larry fitzgerald active
i think don't you think fitz would have
to say i i i'd i'd have to be the fourth
man in here
christian kirk with the five wide
receiver set what do you think
that would be that would be unlawful
[Laughter]
in 50
and you know what you know what's crazy
about and why i say it's unlawful rich
because they're all big guys with
different skill sets
with different gifts and games so it's
the whole football field you cover the
andre hogan goes over anybody here catch
any ball anywhere anytime
and he can play in that slot uh aj green
is great at transitioning in and out of
cuts man it could make
and and julio jones can just flat out do
anything you can just flat out fly
so so you're not duplicating even though
you're duplicating in great size with
all three of them
oh my god we shouldn't even have this
conversation it's like
it's like treason to have that
conversation to be treason against the
nfl to let all those guys play on this
thing
irv i love you you take care of yourself
thanks for the call i miss you
you're the best absolutely man but hey
wait listen
uh all y'all that's trying to take this
is this
julio dissing the cowboy thing like the
cowboys
y'all gotta stop that man that ain't
true that was just um
julio knows if he was with the dallas
cowboys
he knows oh my god his name
oh we'll get we'll see planes fly across
the sky
and just write julio jones and just keep
going
and his name would be so high in the sky
if you put that kind of talent with the
star on the side of his helmet
it would be insane
if there only was uh an amari cooper
photograph with you
and julio jones that he could instagram
out saying remember what we talked about
um but unfortunately i don't think there
is such a thing
all right buddy take care let's take it
that's michael irvin everybody the
people
just to wrap it up uh he says the people
that aaron rodgers were referring to
were the dead presidents
on uh denominations of uh u.s uh
currency
um he said julio jones knows the cowboys
are worth joining because they're
winning unk talk uh unk is uh shannon
sharp
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here